All praise is due to
Allah. We praise Him, seek His help,
and ask for His forgiveness. We seek refuge in Allah from the evil of
our own souls and the evil of
our deeds. Whoever Allah guides, none can lead astray, and whoever He leads astray,
none can guide. I bear witness that there is no god but
Allah alone, without partner, and I bear witness that Muhammad is His servant and
Messenger.  O you who have believed, fear Allah as He should be feared and do
not die except as Muslims.
O mankind, fear your Lord, who
created you from
one soul and created from it its
mate and dispersed from both of them many men
and women. And fear Allah, through whom you ask one another, and the wombs,
if He is ever an
Observer over you. O you who have believed, fear Allah and speak words of appropriate justice. He will
then amend for you
your deeds and forgive you
your sins. And whoever obeys Allah and His
Messenger has certainly attained a
great attainment. Now then, the truest speech is the speech of
Allah, and the best guidance is the guidance of Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him. And the
worst of matters are those that are newly invented, and every newly invented matter is an innovation, and every innovation is
misguidance, and every misguidance is in the Fire. Now then, O
beloved ones in
Allah, Allah created us to worship Him. And I did
not create the jinn and mankind except to
worship Me. I do not want from them any provision, nor do I want them to feed Me. Indeed, it is
Allah who is the Provider, the Possessor of strength, the
Firm. Allah, the Exalted,
I have not created
concept for me.
God
Almighty, and they were not commanded except to worship God, being sincere to
Him in religion, being upright, and to establish prayer and to give
zakah. And that is the religion of the correct path.
Prayer and peace and sister bless, we are here for our relationship.
God Almighty and God.
God, worship. God Almighty and
God Almighty. Mention the letter Alif. Do
people think that they will be left alone because they say, “We believe,” and will
not be
tested? And We have certainly tested those before them, and
God will surely make evident those who are truthful, and He will not make evident the
liars. The letter Alif. I don't have the
disconnected letters. The disconnected letters.
Scholars of the disconnected letters. The letter Alif. Ra. Fif. Kaf. Ha. Ya. Ain. Sif. Qaf. Fif. Lam. Ra. Fif. Nun. The
disconnected letters. God Almighty. The
Quran. Sheikh of
Islam. Al-
Shanqi. Scholars of the
Sunnah. The disconnected letters. God. The disconnected
letters.
Pictures of the letter Alif. That is the Book about which there is no doubt. Sad. And
the Quran. The Reminder. Qaf. And the glorious Quran. Al-Ma'arij.
These are the verses of the clear Book. Indeed, We have sent it down as an
Arabic Quran so that you may understand. Ha Mim. The revelation of the
Book is from God, the Exalted in Might.  The All-Knowing, that I place the verses of
God, the Exalted, and follow the Arabic language,
even though it is the
Arabic language. God, the Exalted, the Most High, the Quran, a Book We have sent down to you, blessed, that they may ponder its verses and that the first may remember. God, Joseph, those are the verses of the clear Book. We have sent it down as an Arabic Quran so that you may
understand. Ibn
Taymiyyah, the Most High, the Most High, from Surah
Al Imran: He is the One Who has sent down to you the Book. In it are
verses that are
clear and decisive. They are the foundation of the Book, and others that are ambiguous. As for those in whose hearts is deviation, they follow that which is ambiguous in it, seeking discord and seeking its interpretation. And none knows its interpretation except
God and those firmly grounded in knowledge. To the end of the verses. So that is the meaning of the verses.
The reading pours forth readings, and none knows its interpretation except
Allah and those firmly grounded in knowledge.
Only those firmly grounded in
knowledge say, "We believe in it." [
Music]
Allah reads.
Allah reads. Allah reads.
Only Allah seeks
refuge in
Allah. A hadith, peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music]
Some
servantly. A good
reading of
Allah. Interpretation. A good
interpretation.
Allah, Glory be to Him, the Exalted, describes Himself,
but do we know the real way Allah, Glory be to Him, looks? No one knows. Do we know the reality of Paradise? How does it look? We don't know. Do you know how the verses will be, even though Allah told us about the verses, the events that will occur on the Resurrection? But do we know exactly how they will take place? We don't know
the reality of it. So if you put at Allah, meaning the reality
of Allah, Glory be to Him, and the
following:
Allah, the beautiful, the detailed, the interpreter, the
interpreter. May Allah bless
you.
Benefit. So you
have to know, you have to learn
to protect our souls from
misconception, and it doesn't mean you
listen to
people and
People, Allah protect
you, protect your family, may Allah bless
you.
So Allah, the Exalted, the Most High ...
done in accordance
with the sun
of the proof of the first condition, God
Almighty and the following mention: “And that they may worship God, being
sincere to Him in religion, not except
worship of God Almighty.” The hadith of the Chosen One,
peace and blessings be upon him, Abu Hafs Umar ibn al-Khattab, may God be pleased with
him: “Actions are but by intentions, and
every person will have only what he intended.”
As
other to
accept the Chosen One, peace and blessings be upon him,
God, peace and blessings be upon him,
the hadith of our mother Aisha, may God be pleased with her: “Whoever does an action that is
not in accordance with our command, it is rejected.” And in another narration: “
Whoever introduces into this matter of ours that which is not part of it, it is
rejected.” Introduces
our
reed in
giving charity, any act of worship, and this gives us, my dear brothers and sisters, may God bless,
give us a scale, give us criteria to judge people, as mentioned
before, people say: “Don’t judge me
of judg, don’t judge
people by going jahann, because the decision
goes back to
Allah. If someone is to innovate, to
misguidance, or he is doing which in
opposition to the Qur’an and Sunnah, then yes, then we
judge. We say you are opposing the  quran
the sunah or someone on social media
openly promoting haram calling to haram
you say yes you are calling to evil yes
are you Ok, forbidden,
forbidden, heresies and misguidance
knowledge, the good of the
outward and the inward, the Chosen
One,
peace be upon him,
of this life
is in everything and one of the things
that we have been tried with many we see many young
brothers turn away from the
of
Allah and getting involved in Britain we
call it a road man lifestyle or
gangle which is way is an evil way
And if you follow that the of
gang life or road lifestyle without any
doubt going to lead you to either to the
graveyard or to prison or you go
subhanah some people end up going
mentally of drugs and alcohol and so on
and of course as a believer we should
not expose our sins but you know I some
of you may have heard me many times
mentioning in my videos me
myself and was evil thing Allah for me
and I was involved in this evil
lifestyle and there is nothing praise
worthy about it it's evil disgusting and
you just always
feel in a state of fear and always
depression  don't let them deceive you
when they are making videos  Singing,
praising, glorifying, and glamorizing. Deep down, areess, deep down.
God Almighty, the Most Truthful of the truthful. And
whoever turns away from My remembrance - indeed, he will have a
life of hardship. God Almighty,
only in the remembrance of God do hearts find rest.
Happen, ultimate happiness.
God
Almighty involves drugs. People kill each other because of
postcode, rather than kill each other because of postcode, because of what they call it, because of friends, evil. And teaching
our words about it. As a Muslim, you have to love for the sake of Allah. You love the believer, you have to love the believers. And you hate for the sake of Allah. You hate
those who oppose Allah and His Messenger. So how can you hate those who oppose
Allah and His Messenger? Indeed, your Lord, the Most High, the Most Glorified ...
Rivers
flowing, they will abide therein eternally. Allah is pleased with them and they are pleased with Him.
Those are the party of Allah. Indeed, the party of Allah are the successful ones. Allah
has inscribed faith in their hearts, the believers in their hearts,
and has shown them
proof, light, and true
guidance from Himself. He will admit them to Paradise, and
rivers flowing therein for them to dwell in forever.
Allah is pleased with them and they will be
pleased.
[Music] Allah,
Blessed and Exalted is He.
Allah, and we seek refuge in Him from
darkness. We seek refuge in Him from things
outside. They are always happy. They are always scared for
their lives. As mentioned, they are always in this state,
but a believer who follows
the path is always happy regardless. You don't
have to take drugs.
[Music] Praise be to
Allah.
Understand Allah, the Most High.
Allah, the Most High.
Good. Glory be to Him. The post that does not belong
to any of them.  It belongs to the
government, but if the government decides
to remove you to the other post code
which you are fighting and what you are going to do now,
killing each other for the sake of a post,
shows us the outcome of 10 from
Allah, Subhanah. We start doing
foolishness, and as you
[music]
The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: “The believer remains
within the bounds of his religion, within the scope of his religion, as long as he does not shed
forbidden blood,” or as he, peace and blessings be upon him, said.
Subhan Allah, Subhan Allah, Exalted is He.
Now, for that reason, We decreed upon the Children of Israel that whoever
kills a soul unless for a soul or for corruption [done] in the
land – it is as if he had killed all of mankind. And whoever saves one – it is
as if he had saved all of mankind. And Our
messengers had certainly come to them with clear proofs. Then indeed, many of them, after that, throughout the
land, were transgressors. The meaning of murder or not spreading mischief in
the
land is that it would be as if he killed all of mankind. The mention means that if this individual believes it is
permissible for
him to kill someone unjustly, then you
have no right to kill other people.
So, because Allah already mentioned  I'm
allow to kill someone unjly so ring that
he believes
doesn't only apply for specific person
applies for the whole mankind that you
allow to kill people unjustly this is
the meaning of the verse
as mercy upon him mentioned
and my brothers shows us here the jtice
of Islamic law
Islamic law
Islamic law nocept
Islam means law more specific more
accurate divine law means divine law so
the divine law the hud the capital
Allah legislated it for our
own  benefits to protect us from the evil
doers to protect us from the criminal so
why some
with as they are ignorant or have been
misinformed about it or themselves are
what criminals for Islam if you kill
someone unjustly then accord to Islamic
legislation then your s be taken to
because you have no respect for people's
lives
imagine these young brothers guide
them if they say you know if I'm going to
kill someone now they are going to take
my
twice going to
what if kill me do it so how many lives
saved how many  lives saved life and
other
life that's
why
the ransom
is  There is a
good
[music]
UK. How can we resolve the problem?  Put
them in prison we are already doing that and
the just keeps
increasing.  We have to do this.  I said
look who knows better than the creator
no
one Allah knows about us better than
anyone else.  So when Allah legislates
this law, He knows this law will
stop people from committing crimes or
will decrease them, at least it will decrease them.
But if you know that you are going to commit
a crime, then the consequence of it is that you will be put in prison. Sometimes you will be treated better than the victim. By
God, what kind of law is this injustice? But we as Muslims, we, God Almighty, and ...
He does
n't care ang doesn't care who your
friends which you belong to which gang
you belong to.  Rather look at the story
of Siman, the king.  They say four kings
rule the world.  One of them
is the whole world, peace be upon him, King Solomon,
and King Solomon's palace, and his palace
was well protected. No one was able to
enter his palace. So once he went to
his backyard and he saw a man standing there. He said, "Who are you?
How did you enter my palace
when my palace is
protected?" The soldiers of Adam, from God, Solomon, peace be upon him, protect you
when God decrees and commands. You come to your life for it, even your friends, your loved ones, your
father and
your mother love you so much and are able to help you.
You came as if
We had not created you the first time, and you left behind you what We had entrusted to you.
God, the
Exalted, says, "If you could only see when the wrongdoers are in the throes of
death, and the angels are stretching out their hands, saying, 'Release your souls!
Today you will be recompensed with the punishment of humiliation for what you used to
say against God other than the truth and for your arrogance toward His verses.'"
God,
Muhammad
[applause]
God, the Exalted, Glory be to God.
I was immersed in this evil, disgusting,
dirty
lifestyle. You
know, some of us might want to leave
this lifestyle, but it's too hard. I myself was
facing this problem.  I
remember when we used to
live only at night, we would only go out
at night, during the day we would just sleep, and I always told this
story many times. I used to say,
when I'm going
back home around 5:00, "
Subhan
Allah, Astaghfirullah,
Surah Az-
Zumar
5: 'Is one who is devoutly obedient
during the night, prostrating and standing [in prayer], fearing the Hereafter and
hoping for the mercy of his Lord, [like one who is not]? Say, 'Are those who know equal to
those who do not know?' Only those of understanding will remember.
Allah, the Exalted, the
Almighty, says in prayer, 'Allah is the Most High.' [Applause] Allah is the Most High. Are those who know equal to those who do not know? [Applause] I always need to change. People are praying. People are doing [Applause], 'Could help me.' [Applause] I washed my friend for a
year. You know, I was making Allah,
that was my
point. I see people inside accepting Islam, practicing Islam,
so I said to
myself, 'Bless me with a Muslim family. Allah bless me with Islam from the time I was born.' So
that's why you never appreciate
something until
you have friends
around you. Good witness, may Allah bless you. You have to have friends around you."
advice to me and all of you my de and
something you
know we have brothers out
there speaking
about gangle in detail which is not with
Islam because why you exposing sins more
and more also sometimes instead
of worry and you start glamoring
ok
so this one point the other point I want
to
mention some of us here you know what
will happen to us of
experience some people they will
never change their lifestyle until
something bad happened to them
regardless how much remind them and some
of them they would die before
that and some of them Maybe they go
mentally they go crazy and God forbid
maybe God will show them with his
mercy before too late.  So none of us we
are guaranteed to be from those Allah
will shower us with His mercy before too
late.  So why are we going to take the
risk?  Why do we go? Why are we going to take the
risk when we
know being open and
upright is a
blessing? This lifestyle, this life, speaking Harley,
the whole life is temp. Sooner
or later, we are going to this life. Either way, we are going.
[Music]
Good deeds, bad
deeds, God Almighty, Quran, "We have guided him to
the way, whether he be grateful or
ungrateful." God
[Music]
The scholar Sheikh Zaid bin Hadi Al-Madkhali, God, Hell, and we seek
refuge in God, Hell, righteousness, God Almighty,
God, make up here
after, so don't
be
gr from. Excuse me,
the seven forbidden things: associating partners with God and disbelief. Good,
return,
good, faith, faith,
God willing, his faith
increases with obedience to the Most Merciful, and
decreases with obedience to Satan.
Satan,
good, God Almighty, may
God bless you. [Music] In the Muslim who is a gang member, he should know that remaining loyal to his gang will be in to be with your gang or with your crew or with your evil friends. Then he is an infidel. God bless
you. Your Islamic creed
could
have seen
[Applause]
Love and disavowal, and
God forbid, loyalty and disavowal,
loyalty and disavowal based upon the
Quran, for the sake of God,
good enemies of
Islam, the foundation of the foundations of religion, loyalty and disavowal, good loyalty and disavowal.
From our human nature to love, correct, from our human
nature to hate, correct. We cannot change human nature. You cannot love, you can hate. It's impossible, but Islam comes in and tells you to love with justice and to
hate with
justice because some of us sometimes
hate someone and end up doing what, lying
against him, slandering him, oppressing
him. But Islam comes in, doesn't mean
because you hate him. Allow him, allow him, allow
me. Malik [
music]
Suraq ibn
Malik, Suraq ibn
Malik, the Prophet
[music]
upon him,
your father, Suraqah.
I was with my friends outside my house.
A servant came to me and said, "I saw
two people
traveling towards
Medina. I think it was Muhammad and his
companion Malik." He said, "No, I know those
two people. Who did you see?" He said, "
The reason I said that is
because I don't want my friend to take [something]. I want to take the [something]. So
then I left to do something." I
went to
Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him. Muhammad, peace and blessings be
upon him. Abu
Bakr, Abu Bakr. [
Music]
[Applause] May
God bless you, Suraqah.
I'm telling
you how Suraqah broke
Mecca.
So
may the king of
the respect this owns half of the
world. He's a king of half the world. He is
telling him that you are going to dress you in
his own
garments. So he was to
make sure.
[Music]
Great break of
the Romans. May
God break him, peace and blessings be upon him. Your
father Suraqah, son of Malik. [Music]
Break of Omar bin
[Music]
Al-Khattab of
his. Where is Suraqah?
Suraqah, Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him. [
Music] Right, peace and blessings be upon him. [Music] And
God's glory. The
Quran. They were shepherds, then they became strong
[Music]
The Nations 25
Years from the border of China to Africa, the
order of
all that was the Islamic
empire.
Now we complain to
Allah, we say why are we going to
foration? The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said: “A group from my nation will remain victorious upon the truth. Those who forsake them or oppose them will not harm them until the command of Allah comes, and they will be upon guidance,” or as he, peace and blessings be upon him, said. [
Music]
[Music] And
peace be upon you. [Music] Ring, may Allah
bless you. May Allah
bless you. Allah, the Exalted, the Almighty.
Allah, the Exalted. [Music] And after Allah. [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
Well, thank God,
Ramadan is good,
God willing.
[Music]